bonjour ceci tient là soyez gentils ne
fait pas de bruit on va entendre voler
une mouche oui figurez vous que une fois
par mois nous nous réunissons ici dans
le silence le plus complet et nous nous
consacrons à la lecture à sow lille
france est de ta chance figurez vous que
j'ai appris dans ce livre géographe
kolaté
vous le saviez il me semble que j'ai un
vendeur de parler mais ça mais
savez-vous ml
nous que je lis une heure avant de
m'endormir tous les soirs au moins cinq
minutes pas davantage voulez vous je ne
peux pas plus j'ai tellement sommeil
c'est vrai je ne dépense tellement toute
la journée que le cabba jacques lutz a
bien sûr je comprends très bien mon cher
ami veut pas tous fermés mais moi
j'arrive du métaux à vouziers quoi c'est
un salon l'écumé sinon tu te calmes et à
raison vous fait trop de bruit tous les
deux en fait le nar que li ti de bojan
réduit
tu es toujours plongé dans les mémoires
de casimir envoyé plus de chamonix tue
c'est grâce à jean vivant figure
sinistre
mais
avouez que vous n'êtes pas drôle tous
les jours je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord avec toi léonard pas du tout
mais comment peux tu dire ça nous
passons notre temps à rire ça alors
c'est bien vrai n'est ce pas là pour
courir
mes pauvres amis sentent le fabriquer
100 au toit je me demande qui pourrait
bientôt ferrari il
casimir parle dans ses mémoires de pique
niquons et de son équipe je pense qu'il
m'amuserait ça effectivement ils sont
pas tristes
faites vous là et bien voyons léonard
nous lisons en fin du mois de mai s'est
vu de l'étude pour aujourd'hui un filet
me chercher pique niquons et ses
complices c'est un ancien de la fatalité
volonté de loire le lot ils vont me up
est content on est d'accord enfin
j'espère qu'ils sont aussi drôles que
l'écrit casimir parce que moi je le
connais quasiment il répond un lien
tandis que moi c'est autre chose il me
faut des gags plein de finesse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà mes enfants nous avons fait le
ménage il n'y a plus qu'à attendre les
clous
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour mais si les rennais
l'émoi m vous disiez sont des autres
n'est plus amène à vous nous avez voulu
vous nous avez regardé nous et rigoler
j'ai déjà commencé vous êtes sirat
estime with andy moi mon petit camara
tout d'abord les autres vous attendent
que ça s'arrête
joulia et cuillère mais oui votre cheval
mademoiselle julien bayou et je les
laissais à l'écurie parce que il est un
peu enrhumé
[Applaudissements]
mais revenons à notre sens cheval une
écuyère c'est zéro
beaucoup d'auteurs et alors oui oui je
sais jongler je suis jongleuse je jongle
très bien avec ma baguette regardez
joly à vous n'avez mais votre baguette
dans la
jatte en ce genre de conneries ça c'est
mon grand coupet messieurs crème fraîche
mais avec son affaire mais il est
peut-être fait
je n'ai jamais tant ri comment
s'appelle-t-il celui-là ça c'est mon
boulot copains mais ces chenilles que
l'eau
dangereuse la jambe
quelle équipe et vous comment vous
appelez-vous
la guinée lé minium pique au jeu mais
pourquoi vous appelle t-on ainsi et
thouars de pique nique aux
tirs étaient parfois c'est fois c'est
parti sa maman de donner le biberon mais
quand il devint plus grand en grand
nombre ils n'acceptent qu'une seule
manière de manger les pique niques
et c'est pourquoi au petit déjeuner
déjeuner goûter nous repas du soir il
est temps et le petit n'a sur l'herbe
près du cirque et là où mes yeux tout
charme de petits poissons 8 me et au
roulement et la soul et le blues
beaucoup joué aussi parfois de
l'avènement et madame la pluie est apte
à y est ici
c'est pourquoi on l'appelle pique nique
mais c'est une très jolie histoire
monsieur pique niquons quand la vente
non seulement vous êtes clown mais ans
quand vous êtes prêts forcément pas
tellement les abdos les amis ils sont
les clones des petits enfants sont
forcément des poètes comme s'ils sont
ici et musiciens alors musique
[Musique]